- Don't be an asshole, period.
And that pretty much covers it,
and also, you can go right
into the Golden Rule,
treat people like you wanna be treated.
(cheerful music)
- [Voiceover] Well hey there.
Look, it's Willie.
- [Voiceover] In the 1930s,
Willie Nelson was a small-town kid.
He was also an extreme nose-picker.
He'd pick until he bled,
and Willie became an
easy target for bullies.
(laughter)
- When I was like six years old,
my grandmother had taught
me this poem, said,
what are you looking at me for?
I ain't got nothing to say.
If you don't like the looks of me,
you can just look the other way.
And I thought it was so funny,
I started living that way (laughs).
- [Voiceover] He learned
to ignore the teasing
and look the other way.
And years later, that lesson still stands.
- Well, I think you have
to follow your feelings,
do what your conscience tells you to do.
If you feel like you can do anything,
whether it's this cause or that cause,
I think you're obligated to do it.
- [Voiceover] For Willie,
offering a helping hand
has played an important role.
He's supported dozens of environmental
and humanitarian causes over the years.
- I feel like we're all
responsible for each other, you know.
If you see somebody
out need some help,
you help 'em, if you see
somebody's cow in a ditch,
you help 'em pull ‘er out.
(cow lowing)
(laughter)
I like to think that we all gotta be
as good an example as we can be,
whether it's to our kids
or to the whole world.
(cheerful music)